الرحلات المدنيه الايرانيه الى لبنان تهرب
السلاح اسرائيل تكشف عن مسار جديد لتهريب
سلاح ايران الى ميليشيا حزب الله هذه
المره عبر خطوط معراج التابعه للحرس
الثوري بشكل الاسبوعي يشهد مطار بيروت
الدولي هبوطه رحلات ايرانيه تابعه لشركه
معان اير وايران اير لكن في الاسابيع
الاخيره بدات شركه معراج الايرانيه بتسيير
رحلاتها الى لبنان في نهج غير اعتيادي حطت
الرحله الاولى في الرابعه عشر من نوفمبر
مصادر العربيه افادت ان رحلات معراج
لبيروت قد تنقل اسلحه ومعدات حساسه لحزب
الله وان اسرائيل تخشى انضمامه مطار بيروت
الى مسار تهريب الاسلحه من ايران للبنان
عبر هذه الرحلات
المصادر اكدت ان هذا النوع من المحور في
نقل الاسلحه فيعرض لبنان للخطر عدا ان
استغلال مطار بيروت في نقل اسلحه ايرانيه
سيضر بالاقتصاد اللبناني وقد يعرض لبنان
للعقوبات والعزله الدوليه
على مر السنوات
القدس على نقل اسلحه من ايران الى سوريا
ومن هناك الى لبنان مثل مكونات انظمه
الدفاع جوي وصواريخ ارض ارض دقيقه بهدف
تعزيز دور مليشي حزب الله وتقويته بالسلاح
نقل المعدات الى لبنان يمر عبر محاوره
متعدده المحور البري وذلك باستخدام شاحنات
والمركبات وعبورها المعابر الحدوديه من
العراق الى سوريا المحور البحري باستخدام
السفن الايرانيه التي تبحر الى ميناء
اللاذقيه في سوريا والمحور الجوي من ايران
الى سوريا باستخدام الخطوط الجويه
الايرانيه ومن هناك الى لبنان عبر وكلاء
النقل التابعين لميليشيا حزب الله ملوك
الشيخ العربيه